[Musique]
il
oui
bien épaulé tenais bonjour merci d'être
ici au théâtre montansier vous êtes le
commissaire d'une exposition qui a lieu
actuellement aux archives communales de
versailles
et cette exposition s'appelle le montant
sus un théâtre pour versailles voilà
merci qui a déjà démarré et qui va taire
se terminer en décembre
parallèlement là nous sommes dans le
foyer du théâtre montansier à versailles
parce qu'ici se passe différents
événements en rapport avec les deux cent
quarante ans du théâtre et nous allons
donc en parler avec vous avec plaisir
voilà donc vous vous êtes versailles et
pierre et paul i télé c'est ça et quelle
est votre fonction actuelle à part comme
isère alors en ce moment je suis
conservateur au palais des ducs de
lorraine à nancy comme m'occupe des
collections du 15e au xviiie siècle
ok et donc vous êtes depuis là c'est
votre première exposition en tant que
commissaire dont c'est la troisième
choix mais là donc la première à
versailles avait sur et voilà votre
ville natale
voilà alors on va raconter un peu
l'histoire de ce théâtre qui est unique
en europe ce que ça avait plus anciens
théâtres à l'italienne européen
dites nous comment ça a démarré alors
c'est en effet l'un des plus vieux
théâtre à l'italienne de france
puisqu'il est sans doute le troisième
après celui de mai c'est celui de gauche
qui a été conservée donc et qui a donc
été inauguré il ya deux cent quarante
ans donc on a la chance de fêter ce bel
anniversaire cette année
et donc il fait partie des premiers
théâtres en france puisque il faut
attendre le milieu du xviiie siècle
avant que ne soit créée ces nouveaux
bâtiments donc dans le dans le paysage
français d'accord alors quatre îles
italiennes en gros ça veut dire quoi
qu'elles soient légales et éthiques
alors c'est un
un théâtre qui vient d'italie comme sont
dans la dir qui change la forme du
théâtre a dit auparavant les théâtres
français avait une forme allongée qui
reprenait notamment la forme des salles
de jeu de paume donc tout à fait
rectangulaire assez peu pratique pour
les spectateurs et le théâtre à
l'italienne prend cette forme en
hémicycle qui évidemment permet de
beaucoup mieux voir et entendre le
spectacle qui est donné d'accord et qui
permet aussi je crois de voir et d'être
vu exactement alors évidemment au xviiie
siècle le théâtre et très social est un
roc social social très important on se
montre également dans les loges dans les
loges de théâtre et la couleur y est
également pour quelque chose on dit que
la couleur du xviiie au théâtre c'est le
bleu et le vert ont choisi parce que
cela permet de mettre en valeur le
costume des dames
donc les dames ont aussi un rôle à jouer
dans la décoration ce traitement est
finalement à des parades pour le vent la
haute société
d'accord alors dites-moi qui est à
l'origine de ce théâtre alors une
personnalité assez hors du commun qui
est donc marguerite brune est n'est plus
sous le nom de la montansier qu'elle a
qu'elle a choisie qui est une femme au
destin extraordinaire une femme
d'affaires du xviiie siècle qui a décidé
de se lancer dans une carrière théâtrale
et en obtenant très vite le privilège
d'un certain nombre de théâtre un peu
partout en france
elle en avait plus parce qu'elle en
avait un certain nombre exact elle avait
un privilège qui couvrait pratiquement
tout l'ouest de la france d'accord quand
on regarde aujourd'hui ça paraît assez
assez exceptionnel elle a fait
construire donc un certain nombre de
théâtre dont celui ci dont celui là
qu'elle allait démarrer quand alors ça a
été assez long elle arrive à versailles
dans les années 1760 et à ce moment-là
il existe déjà un autre théâtre à
versailles
quelle est la rue royale ah oui voilà
qui n'existe tinée alors qu'ils n'ont
qui ne dépasserait pas 500 alors dont le
tout premier il ya eu deux salles y en a
eu 1 rue saint-honoré où il ya passé la
soixantaine de places il ya un plus
grand rue royale où il y avait à peu
près 600 600 places mais donc elle se
sent très vite à l'étroit et elle veut
un théâtre plus central plus près du
château donc oui il ya un lien très fort
parce que finalement tu mon outre le
fait qu'il est été inaugurée par louis
saez et marie-antoinette c'était une
volonté de leur part cette création il
ya deux blessures et comment le
définissez à l'époque alors c'était
l'été à deux coups le théâtre ne
s'appelait pas théâtre montansier nord
il a une à qui ce nom qu'au xxème siècle
donc très tardivement c'était la comédie
de la ville d'accord il avait en effet
la spécificité d'être le pivot entre la
ville de versailles et le château
puisque les spectateurs qui venaient
assister au spectacle était à la fois dé
versailles et et des membres de la cour
et de la famille royale et des parisiens
n'ont pas aidé parisien également qu'ils
venaient se presser à sa programmation
absolument d'entre elles était un lieu
extrêmement prestigieux parce que vous
pouvez apercevoir la cour exactement
du spectacle en fait voilà c'est un lieu
de société extraordinaire des cas on
n'avait pas l'opéra royal
oui parce qu'il existe deux salles de
spectacle entre guillemets à l'intérieur
du château
voilà qui sont assurés à noé le de
théâtre du trianon un petit peu le petit
le grand frère le petit frère du monde
entier oui mais qui n'étaient consacrer
qu'à la cour où ils attentent reçoit
voilà qui est dans le petit théâtre de
la reine encore plus choisis pour les
intimes de la reine ça va mal à un
public très réduit et est ce que les
spectacles je crois que suivait la cour
alors on line et acier avait en effet un
le privilège des spectacles à la suite
de la course est à dire que c'est elle
qui gérait avec ses comédiens
les spectacles à versailles à marly à
saint cloud à compiègne partout se
rendaient la famille royale des corps
donc elle avait un rôle extrêmement
important à l'extrême entérite brunet et
elle était proche de marie antoinette ou
paris elle était proche de la reine
on sait qu'elle a réussi à rentrer dans
ses lancers bonne grâce au théâtre de la
rue royale et était sans théâtre qui
était au départ le gardien facto plus
parce qu'après la hulpe palais royal à
paris elle a eu deux le palais au bar
dont le thème de la royale aversa oui
mais elle a eu également ensuite le
théâtre du palais royal à paris est le
premier à s'être appelée théâtre
montansier d'accord donc là je veux
rester dans sa carrière en fin de
carrière à la révolution qu'est ce qui
se passe alors la révolution c'est une
période assez compliquée à la fois pour
la montansier et pour le théâtre elle
quitte versailles pour paris en suivant
la famille royale elle est incarcérée à
paris pendant plusieurs mois on va
l'accuser évidemment d'avoir eu des
relations avec la haine donc elle va se
défendre dans deux dans plusieurs
mémoires en déniant complètement ses
relations elle écrivait des mémoires
destiné au tribunal pour ça
qui sont assez assez exceptionnel on
l'attend un bailleur d'or dans
l'exposition aux archives
voilà oui et puis le théâtre de
versailles va être un petit peu
abandonné la municipalité lui envoie des
lettres pour lui dire pourriez vous vous
occupez de la programmation de
versailles et en même temps on programme
ici des spectacles révolutionnaires ont
des programmes d'aidé spectacle jour des
anciennes fêtes catholiques pour montrer
qu'on est vraiment fervents
révolutionnaires
donc c'est vraiment une période assez
particulier l'accord dû la perdre et
détruit mais il a été sauvé sous le
premier empire quelques années plus tard
lorsque napoléon prendre un décret qui
réduit par deux le nombre de spectateurs
en france et l' intention était menacée
de fermeture
oui donc le dernier lien on va dire de
la montansier avec ce théâtre etc elle
le sauve à ce moment-là de la fermeture
d'accord et après la termine sa carrière
je crois vers les 80 ans
exceptionnelle il meurt sous le règne de
louis xviii après avoir traversé un
emploi j'aime assez extraordinaire
d'accord alors on va passer au 19e
siècle si vous voulez bien quelconque
est ce qu'on peut dire sur la vie de ce
théâtre 19e siècle qu'est ce que c'était
l'antichambre des théâtres parisiens aux
fins d'aider ce pays
alors oui la guerre il a eu une période
un peu complexe au 19e siècle puisque
les directeurs vont s'enchaîner assez
fréquemment et avoir beaucoup de mal à
aligner leur budget financier avait pour
deux raisons c'est un gouffre aweys est
un gouffre énorme parce qu'il faut
savoir qu'à l'époque ya plus de 100
personnes dans l'équipe du théâtre ce
qui est gigantesque
dans la demeure inconnue toute la troupe
comprise avaient tout à fait tout
compris d'accord et puis il ya une
diversité de spectacles sidérante
à l'époque ça veut dire diversité des
corps exact de places de tous donc c'est
vieux c'est vraiment un gouffre
financier dans les directeurs en plus
les faire de l'est versailles et sont
assez assez exigeant il faut savoir
qu'il ya pas de chauffage au théâtre
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle donc les
versaillais se caille pontivy c'était
une pièce
et puis surtout il ya la concurrence de
paris qui arrive avec la création du
chemin de fer qui m
évidemment à ces signes visibles pour le
pour le tertiaire la fréquentation et
dites-moi si non alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé au 19ème d'un peu alors le
théâtre doit avancer de montant alors
pour dire le principal de terre devient
municipal au 19e siècle il était pas là
qu'ils étaient jetés par la vie des
corps et puis il a de plusieurs
restaurations
donc il va passer de bleu à rouge
évidemment quelque chose qu'on a du mal
à visualiser aujourd'hui théâtre était
entièrement rouge
on avait toutes les tapisseries
peintures les revêtements des fauteuils
le plafond a changé également plusieurs
fois d'aspect et en 1850 c'est le
peintre ces chants qui crée le plafond
que l'on connaît actuellement
et le sculpteur cruchet qui sculptent
les célèbres caryatides qui sont un peu
les icônes du théâtre aujourd'hui encore
ensuite le théâtre évidemment passe la
première et la deuxième guerre mondiale
et puis la ville a décidé de reprendre
directement le théâtre sans directeur
pendant une courte période et puis à le
diriger malades et voilà dirigé par la
ville mais elle se rend compte bientôt
que c'est impossible à gérer
et elle fait appel à une nouvelle
directrice une femme marcelle 2,7 pour
épouser 2-9 à redonner un nouveau
souffle et actrice comédienne metteur en
scène un terminal très réputée à paris
une enzo extrêmement important et elle
n'aura pas réellement tout à fait à
portée ici avec ses arrières salles tout
et pas les plus grands noms qui est bien
grande c'est l'époque de théâtre ce soir
on a un certain nombre de spectacles qui
sont joués notamment à montansier way et
les parisiens retrouvent vraiment le
chemin du théâtre pour venir encore une
fois montansier voir les spectacles qui
sont créées dont qu'ils étaient créés
uniquement ici où s'étaient préparés
dlf elle faisait venir les spectacles
parisiens à versailles mais elle crée
aussi des spectacles à versailles qui
ensuite tourné un petit peu partout en
fait c'est ce qui se fait aujourd'hui et
c'est ce qui se fait avec cet homme est
finalement d'accord très bien ensuite
fait toute façon tous à tout ce que vous
nous avez raconté expliqué on peut le
voir en images avec des tas de daffy
cette photo est ressorti beaucoup de
beaucoup de documents qui sont présentés
pour la première fois puisque c'est la
première exposition sur le monde entier
voilà alors ces documents il faut aller
les voir aux archives coloniales
voilà près du château et donc ça dure
jusqu'en décembre jusqu'au 2 décembre
jusqu'au 2 décembre
voilà et ici à montansier va se passer
plein d'événements on est déjà passé pas
mal mais ça continue le mois de novembre
est riche en manifestations alors
forcément dans ce que je sais le 18
novembre qui est à ma nouvelle gare est
en plein dans l'anniversaire des deux
cent quarante ans le voilà alors est ce
qu'on peut parler de ce qui va ce qui va
se passer principalement je sais qu'on a
plusieurs représentations tout du long
du mois de novembre
si tu mens un peu plus si vous avez
surtout un très très beau spectacle qui
veulent monter donc du 18 au 25 novembre
la guerre des théâtres qui est un opéra
comique d'accord qui va être montée donc
ici même à montansier avec une
spécificité assez exceptionnel c'est que
le château de versailles a accepté
exceptionnellement de prêter les décors
du petit théâtre de marie antoinette qui
vont donc être monté présenté sur la
scène
raison de ce spectacle éclairée à la
bougie donc on tout comme elle
travaillait pas exactement quinquennal
solly ancien exactement voilà mais à des
spectateurs
appréciant se retrouver le soir
d'inauguration quelque sort exact heures
ne pensiez pas y est ça va être donc une
pièce qui appartient au genre de l'eau
glaciale dans l'alaric qui est
emblématique du xviiie siècle qui mêle à
la fois théâtre théâtre et chant voilà
c'est ça le principe de l'opéra comique
moi je fais un peu l'andouille mais
exactement mais gilles a dit moi et donc
qui inquiète musicien d'orchestre ces
chants des danses et des danseurs tout à
fait exact extrêmement complet comme moi
des gueux l'époque exactement tout à
fait d'accord donc si on veut revivre le
théâtre théâtre bien toi tu as été 1016
dans les mêmes conditions il faut venir
voir ce spectacle il faut venir voir la
toux du tout au long du mois de novembre
mais madame l'exposition se termine la
pareille au début des mois de décembre
et dont elle s'accompagne d'un
vous voyez l humanité que j'obtiens qui
s p tout extrêmement richement illustré
on en trouvera des images plus tard qui
est écrit alors c'est un ouvrage
collectif on travaille à servir nos
déchets il participe aussi corinne
françois de névé martial poirson qui
sont les deux mais parce que si on a
tout à fait très bien mais coûte je
crois qu'on a tout dit mais croyez
tellement de choses à dire merci à tous
d'avoir éclairé de la sorte et puis bah
j'encourage tout le monde à apprendre
ces plaques
voilà non parce que ce sera unique tout
à fait merci bien ce bolide au revoir
il